[Music]
so welcome and we've got a very exciting
and very diverse panel here on the the
future of AI hardware and I'm just going
to go back to something that when Dario
was talking earlier this morning and if
he's talking about that the energy
requirements I mean the the compute
requirements are doubling every three
point five months through that
production you know if you follow this
out I think the estimate right now is by
2040 AI on this current trajectory will
exhaust all of the energy in in the
world not that obviously is not going to
happen but what we have today is a panel
that's going to talk about how is AI
Hardware going to to advance so I think
what we're gonna do is we're gonna bring
up each of the panelists they'll
introduce themselves quickly and do a
very short five-minute kind of
introduction on their point of view and
then we'll go to slide o and start the
conversation sound good
everybody's still awake awesome okay I
think with that we're going to start out
come on come on up Andrew and and you if
you could just introduce yourself and
your affiliation really quickly and then
we'll oh no you don't do you need any
hardware yeah when the time comes all
right some hardware guys got you
hardware is that okay yeah we good okay
hello everyone I'm Andrew McCallum on
the faculty at UMass Amherst where I
also direct the Center for data science
and I'm very grateful and happy to be
part of this IBM collaboration in two
days at a workshop I'll talk about my
research in natural language processing
and knowledge-based building but here
I'm really I'm here to talk about a sort
of a side project in an understanding
energy and policy considerations which
was really instigated by one of my
students MSU Bell is just not working
there we go sorry who's now on our way
to a faculty position at Carnegie Mellon
all right so we're facing some large
problems in the world and AI can be part
of the solution right by helping us do a
better evidence based decision making
in the midst of these problems and there
are many sources of that evidence and
one of them actually comes from from
text there's there's a large quality of
information in text and let's consider
for a moment scientific text so one
example we are working together with an
MIT professor of materials science named
Elsa Olivetti - starting with hundreds
of thousands of research papers in
material science extracting from them
the recipes sorry there's a really bad
delay with this uh with this remote the
recipes for synthesizing new materials
for car batteries of the future or a
better recycling processes so that once
we had this large collection we can
infer perhaps brand-new recipes that
have never been tried before that may
have good properties and understanding
this text if I was quite a bit of
natural language processing
understanding its structure to really
understand its deep semantics and the
operation that's mostly needed is called
syntactic parsing and the reason that
it's considered it's no reasonable to
actually try to apply this and in this
environment now or to this type of data
is that accuracy is already after much
research arrived at a point that it's
really useful so maybe back in the 1990s
when people were using context-free
grammars we were I had accuracy less
than 75 but now thanks to machine
learning and now deep learning we have
accuracies up up in the 90s and and so
now like you know doing natural language
processing is not just a matter of
academic interest that we write in
papers but you know it's a matter of
large-scale processing by massive
companies that are trying to run this on
the entire web and so that makes its
efficiency quite important and one of
these models actually look like well
they're transformers
there's attention based models of the
kind of yahshua I mentioned at the
beginning of the day so starting with
word embeddings for all of these
projecting them into three different
spaces through various transformations
and then making an N squared comparison
amongst all of them to decide attention
to weights through which information is
shared across all of them if they're
then furthermore there's not just one
attention head but many attention heads
these the results of all of them are
then brought together through further
processing and the result is then
brought back down to the beginning where
this entire process is run again
many times so you can see that involves
a tremendous amount of computation tens
of millions or hundreds of millions of
parameters and there's been a whole
propagation of new machine learning
models of larger and larger computation
that for some reasons seem to be named
after Sesame Street characters so there
was Elmo a few years ago that really
caused some big gains and not just like
it's processing accuracy now of course
many of us know about this method called
Burt and here I've plotted them on a
scale with GPU our just to train on the
horizontal axis and this is on a log
scale right and so it's really growing
very dramatically up at the top there is
a method on evolved transformers that
I'll be talking about more in a bit so
this uses a tremendous amount of
processing power tremendous amount of
energy and then also a lot of carbon so
putting carbon into the atmosphere so AI
is not only part of the solution it's
part of the becoming part of the problem
so I want to put this into perspective
in the following way so if you fly from
New York City to San Francisco you've
used you know almost 2,000 pounds of
carbon dioxide
the average American life uses about
36,000 and a model that we in my lab
trained and sent to email people were
fortunate enough to win the best paper
award the entire research development of
that model took more than two American
lifetimes of carbon in order to produce
something he weren't really aware of
until we thought about this and if you
take this large transformer with neural
architecture search then you get
something that looks more like five
times the amount of carbon of the entire
lifetimes use of a car to train to it to
develop one model all right so this is
the manufacturing of the car gathering
all of its materials producing the steel
driving it all of its fuel that entire
time this mod what did this model give
us it gave us point one percent an
improvement on a machine translation
task I don't think the researchers were
really thinking about the impact of what
they were doing and so let me just wrap
up by saying that so I use this a
tremendous amount of carbon it also uses
quite
cost but these are dollars calculate in
terms of cloud computing credits and
hardware can help if you use say a
tensor processing unit instead of a GPU
then that helps sum up but this is not a
solution to the problem it only makes
things incremental eat better all right
so first of all researchers should just
be aware of these issues right so and
when we publish a paper we should let
the community know you know how much
training time did it take and what was
the sensitivity hyper parameter that
affects how many times you need to run
it if you're gonna apply it to new data
number two
you know some academic researchers are
fortunate to have massive computing
resources but others not so much and
it's really quite expensive we need to
think about equity I'm almost done
number three researchers should
prioritize and really think in their
research about computationally efficient
methods and so these are researchers in
NLP machine learning generally in
systems we need to think about
algorithms like instead of grid search
for meta parameters been thinking about
smart Bayesian search methods and I
think the my following panelists are
going to talk more about efficient
hardware for doing these things and then
when we come up to discussion I'll have
more to say about algorithms with that
I'll close thank you
looking forward in this different
[Applause]
professor song tongue and song if you
would come up and introduce yourself
briefly and okay great hello everyone my
name is song I'm a assistant professor
at MIT ECS the Microsystems technology
lab I join a mighty last year and before
that I did my PhD at Stanford proposed a
technique called model compression where
we can aggressively compress the size of
the neural networks by 10 to 50 times
without losing the accuracy so the slide
is going backwards can you switch to the
first slide
okay yeah so as the previous talk you
mentioned AI has lots of computation
requirement so I proposed a deep
compression algorithm where we can prune
the redundant parameters and the
quantization to shrink the bit with her
parameter and as a result we can reduce
the computation the model size by 10 to
50 times however those of course another
problem to run on those sparse and
compress the model because I bring
sparsity which is not efficient to run
on conventional hardware therefore I
proposed the efficient universe engine
that can directly work on the compress
this small model rather than inflate the
model to run the inference so recently
and I might here we are working on
making AI efficient with any resource
including both hardware resource and
also human resource especially human
resource that is very expensive and we
want to apply Auto ml Auto ml techniques
to make AI to design better AI and for
computational resource we want to have a
universe with low computation resource
we want to have small model small
computation and when you have a lot of
computational resource you want to have
a scalable distributed training so we
work on this algorithm Haruko design
first proposed new algorithms adapt them
adapt them to require our computation
and also we're designing efficient
hardware that provide more computation
and with human-in-the-loop we are
working on assisted it is an automation
to automatically optimize the neural
network and also automatically design
hardware so this is a big picture for
conventional AI require big data
computation and engineer so in modern
time we wanted to we wanted to do these
automation to reduce the amount of
engineering efforts to tune the
parameters for both the neural net and
the hardware by using a lot of
computation power using the data and
later we are also aiming at reducing the
amount of computation power to train to
do neural architecture search for
example in our
recent work covered by mighty news we
are able to design new architecture
search algorithms that are 200 times
more computationally efficient than
conventional nozzle methods actually
previous newer architecture search took
for more than 48,000 GP hours if you
convert that to US dollars that's
roughly 100 K US dollars which is the
cost of maintaining a PhD student so
when I just joined MIT last year I don't
have those computational resource right
so we design a more efficient algorithm
that can do you know architects research
directly on the target hardware called
peroxidase nas but take only 400 GPU
hours which is the cost of having a
group lunch or group dinner right so we
can shrink the computational resource
but delivering equally good models that
ran fast on your hardware to use AI to
design better AI and we find some
structures that AI found previously
human didn't find which is very
interesting and also talking about but
you have to have lots of computational
resource so IBM last year introduced us
to the Sumida super computer where we
are able to train with a thousand and
five hundred GPUs right so previously we
don't have GPS now we suddenly have so
many GPUs coming well utilize them so my
student came with an efficient model
that kiss scale really well to 1500 536
GPUs but previously when we train those
video understanding models taking two
days now it takes only 14 minutes more
than 200 times speed-up and by designing
the small models smartly it takes the
last networking it takes less I oh
that's the reason it can be more
scalable than those conventional methods
so we have some demos on the diffusion
video understanding we can show you in
late later so this in conclude
conclusion we showed the beauty of the
efficient model design
however an algorithm co.design to enable
scalable distributed training and
efficient inference on those power and
energy constrained devices
thank you next we'll have to hear from
Professor Vivienne say so Vivienne thank
you just introduce yourself briefly and
then thank you very much all right hello
everyone I'm Vivian C I'm a professor in
the EC s department at NIT and so I'm
excited to share with you some of the
research that we're gonna be doing in
our group and how it might relate to the
future of computing in particular I'm
going to emphasize the work that we've
been doing for efficient computing for
AI and robotics I just want to highlight
that this is work in collaboration with
certain Chairman Joel Emmer and Thomas
Health so a lot of the exciting
algorithms that we're seeing today is
happening due to a lot of the process in
the cloud we saw just in the talk two
talks ago about the huge you know carbon
footprint that it emits so there's a lot
of computational challenges there a lot
of the research in our group focused on
how we can move the computing from the
cloud out into the edge though and then
do the computationally locally in the
device and there's many compelling
reasons to do that the first reason is
communication so if you don't want your
system to have to rely on very you know
large communication networks and so if
we want you know this technology to
reach people around the world we want to
have a less of a reliance on
communication we want to bring the
compute locally another reason is
privacy right so there's a lot of
exciting applications for AI these days
that deal with very sensitive data so
for example in the healthcare space when
you're collecting a lot of this
sensitive data you might not want to
push it all to the cloud so again if you
can bring the processing locally to
where the data is being collected you
have much more privacy and also arguably
more security and then finally if you're
talking about applications where you
interact with the real world so for
example if you're talking about let's
say self-driving cars or robotics
latency is really important right you
might not be able to afford to you know
if you're driving down a highway really
quickly wait for the time it takes to
send the data to the cloud wait for it
to be processed come back and take an
action you really want to do the
processing locally to meet these latency
constraints so these are all the reasons
why we want to move the
shooting from the cloud into the device
itself now the main challenge for doing
this is actually power consumption right
so existing processors can consume way
too much power if you're you know
thinking about self-driving cars often
we're talking about up to 3000 watts of
compute and this is gonna be even more
of a challenge if you want to shrink it
down to something that might be the size
of the palm of your hand so for example
your phone or even smaller robots on
these very small form factor devices you
can't afford to have a very large
working yeah a very large battery
because of the weight of the and the
size of the battery so your energy is
limited and then if you look at existing
embedded processors that are typically
used for these even these edge
processing they typically burn over 10
watts whereas on these you know handheld
devices or small devices because of the
heat dissipation you want the power
consumption to be under a watt itself so
how do we go about doing that within our
group so we look at a kind of a holistic
cross layer design so similar is what
saw mention we looked at how do we build
new algorithms that are not not only
accurate but also account for the
complexity of the energy cost right so
how do we make them both efficient and
accurate how do we then build new
hardware to support these algorithms so
often there's a CO design aspect where
you want to have the hardware in the
loop when you're designing the algorithm
itself in terms of designing new
hardware you typically need to design
the hardware from the ground up so you
might have heard a lot about
domain-specific architectures recently
this is because you know transistor the
Moore's Law is really slowing down so
the only way to get more efficiency is
to really strip down the computers and
design them specifically for a given
task and really what we focus here is to
focus on reducing data movements that as
it turns out moving data is much more
expensive than computing on data it's
just like kind of like communication
communicating data is more expensive
than computing on it so even within the
hardware itself we try and figure out
ways to design the new computer
architectures to reduce data movement so
this is a chip called iris that are
designed with Joel Joel Emmer and we
really focused on reducing the power
consumption for inference so it can do
inference and under 1/3 of a watt and
then finally what's also really
important is that we want to look at how
we integrate these compute systems into
an you know computer we're into actual
systems themselves so for example if
you're thinking about applications like
robotics you want to look at the
interplay of both computing sensing and
actuation and opt to optimize across the
entire thing you want to take a really
holistic approach and so what can you
actually do by enabling all these types
of optimizations for energy efficiency
I'll just give you two quick examples
wine is that it turns out there's a wide
range of robotics out there that
actually consume very little power in
terms of actuation right to interact
with the real world so for example you
can imagine lighter-than-air robots that
are kind of like blimps so lifting it is
very cheap miniature satellites that do
deep space exploration doesn't require
too much to stay up there or even very
small origami robots you can imagine for
healthcare applications so all of these
things the actuation powers release low
so as a result the computational power
if you want to make these autonomous
it's also very critical and one of the
key first steps that we've taken towards
this work with certain Karimun is design
hardware for robot localization so if
you're gonna do autonomous navigation
the first thing you have to do is figure
out where you actually are in the world
and where you're actually looking at so
you can imagine from example this here's
a video of like a video coming in and
we're figuring out where we're actually
where the robot actually is in the 3d
space so to the other we built this chip
called Navi on that really optimizes for
this again Navi on really focuses on
reducing data movement we're actually
able to integrate all the data for this
navigation process on on the chip itself
so for this localization process and as
a result we're talking about orders of
magnitude energy reduction compared to a
general-purpose processor another
application space I'm really excited to
share with you is this work on
monitoring neurodegenerative diseases so
we know that dementia affects you know
millions of people around the world one
of the big challenges for this is that
often the way in which you assess a
given disease is very qualitative so a
patient might go to see a doctor and
they asked that ya get asked a series of
questions and might be able to be asked
to draw a clock and the specialist will
assess them and it's often very
expensive to do that so it happens very
infrequently it's also very qualitative
and so as a result we don't get that
much data to help
analyze the patient what's been really
exciting is that recently it's been
shown that eye movements are correlated
with this neurodegenerative diseases and
so if you can measure the eye movement
or the eye reaction time it does show
some indication of these diseases now
typically right now
you know these type of measurements are
also taken in the clinic but if we can
you know bring a eye into the phone and
do a lot of the processing on the phone
you can actually do these tests on your
smartphone itself get an assessment and
then as a result you can take frequent
measurements in the home itself and this
gives the physician by much more richer
data set to help assess the patient's
state of mind so this is in
collaboration of Thomas Thomas Helton I
should also mention that we've recently
been funded by IBM for doing this this
coming cycle so that's basically it so
true the examples are really you know
the key takeaway here is that energy
efficient AI can really extend the reach
of AI for a wide range of applications
beyond the cloud itself so it's very
promising to making AI ubiquitous but in
order to achieve that we really need to
take a cross layer approach and look at
the algorithms the hardware the
applications and the system itself truly
enable all of this so there's more of
this on our website if you're interested
thank you very much
and finally we have Gerry Chow Chow from
IBM and Gerry if you just introduce
yourself briefly sure thank you very
much
so my name is Gerry Chow I'm a senior
manager of quantum technology from IBM
TJ Watson and I'm coming to you guys
today in this panel but from a the other
direction of quantum computing and if
you listen to Dario's keynote this
morning you heard about effectively the
story of the future of computing from
three different parts right so bits you
have neurons and if there's the qubits
part and so I want to talk to you a
little bit about where that really
starts to come in how deployables
systems start to make an impact even
today for actual access to to the
community and really building building
of the basis for the future of
computation so what's an interesting
thing to ask about when we when we look
at computation is effectively what are
the limitations of the systems that we
have today right so I think a lot of us
are here because we are always engaged
in - where does computing take us into
the future we know that there are easier
problems that are handled in polynomial
complexity for our for our traditional
bit based computers but then we also
know that there's a class of problems
which are extremely hard right these are
ones which scale exponentially in the
number of features scale exponentially
in the number of variables and these
include things such as simulating
quantum mechanics itself understanding
chemistry particulars some types of
really very deep neural networks with a
lot of features and so these these
problems we know are difficult for
traditional computers and so are we at
the limit of what we can do with with
our computational model fortunately the
answer is no and that's really thanks to
these beautiful ideas of looking at
bringing quantum mechanics back into
information theory and so this is
looking back into the 1970s where Ralph
Landauer Charlie Bennett were able to
really put the quantum mechanics and
physics of information into into play so
that we can actually find a more
fundamental understanding for how to
process information that of course led
to a lot of many other thought leaders
going into thinking about how you can
actually perform
computations using quantum mechanics to
the point that we define a different
element for for actually computation
rather than just a bit but in fact a
quantum bit or a qubit which allows us
to have these quantum mechanical effects
such as superpositions and entanglement
it effectively changes the rules right
of how the information is processed in
the underlying computation and once that
occurs were able to actually potentially
find ways of extracting more from these
systems that is more efficiently done
than you can with traditional computers
so put it putting it putting it in a
pictorial way our traditional computers
we have inputs and we have outputs and
we want to perform operations bitwise on
those on those on those inputs and
outputs but with a quantum computer
using these quantum mechanical
principles of entanglement and
superposition we have a much richer
access to a computational space it's
effectively exponential in size and so
in between of these inputs and outputs
you you blow up to say 2 to the N if you
have any qubits and now the idea of a
quantum algorithm is how do i best use
those different paths to interfere
destructively interfere wrong solutions
constructively interfere the right
solutions so that at the end you get the
you get an advantage on performing a
particular computation that you'd like
to and so really now this is where we
can start looking into those problems
that were more challenging so finding
also those ones where scale
exponentially in the optimization or
chemistry or machine learning and try to
address them using quantum mechanics so
then we are now actually building real
systems so at IBM we've been working on
building superconducting qubits that
need to be cooled down to extremely low
temperatures we're using using cryogenic
infrastructure this is a picture of our
most advanced system it's called IBM Q
system 1 and it's been engineered in
order for for us to have really high
performance of the underlying underlying
quantum processors so that we can
actually start to do really really good
science on it and even at this current
stage where we are with these quantum
processors which are still which is
still early in terms of the
numbers of qubits were already able to
start to explore some of these problems
that we're talking about so looking at
molecular structure for simple molecules
as well as looking at classification
problems so actually performing a
quantum support vector machine to to
perform a classification task using a
simple quantum processor and these are
results that we were able to publish
interest in just this past year now the
the point here though is also it's
beyond just what the research has done
in our lab we're really excited that we
are able to actually have these systems
hosted on the cloud for anyone to access
we launched the IBM Q experience in 2016
which at the time was just a 5 cubed
processor on the cloud and now we've
expanded to a large number of processors
that are available for different levels
of access for clients and for public
open access but we've really been
excited about the number of users that
were able to get engage with quantum
computing as well as the research output
that's come out of it so 190 plus papers
in just over three years that's
something that I know we wouldn't be
able to do just ourselves within a
laboratory and then we also see this as
a as an important part of building both
the the usage part of the other systems
but also the software stack so a lot of
the work that is going into quantum
community today is to actually build the
open-source software infrastructure for
us this is called kiss kit and we have
various different levels of API so that
different end-users are able to enter
and actually make use of the quantum
processors to learn about how to program
a quantum quantum system with that I
just want to end by saying that right
now we're in in a really exciting phase
where we went from this transition of
science into becoming quantum ready
where we want to engage the community to
get broader buy-in in terms of learning
about quantum so that in a few years
well as we improve these systems and get
to the point where we can actually make
it have an advantage over traditional
computers that were able to actually
leverage the leverage that and have the
community have businesses use it thank
you
so we're gonna get ready and get our
panelists up to the stage thank you very
much sure and then I'm going to get a
crash course in how to use the the
crowdsourcing of questions I guess it
comes up here yes I think however let's
see maybe like let me get out of the way
no I think we're all good so if it's
okay with people Oh I'll ask a couple of
questions and then I'll go to slide oh
is that all right
was that allowed yeah who's my boss okay
Vivian I was very taken by the first of
all thank you all and I was very taken
by you know the specialized hardware I'm
a hardware geek I've got more horsepower
in my pocket right now I brought all my
specialized stuff so you could sign it
but I was I was yeah I've lived in this
world for a while and I know that you
know when you start to do customized
hardware there's always this trade-off
between customizing the hardware and
sort of optimization of software this
sort of urge to early optimize what's
the trade-off between general purpose
with better software and specialized
hardware so it's always kind of an open
question between the the trade-off
between flexibility and efficiency so
ideally you'd like that everything to be
flexible you can support the future
proof but there's often costs that are
associated with that whereas if you have
very very specialized for a given task
then you don't have all that flexibility
overhead but it's also can be very
efficient so I think it really depends
on the type of application so I've
worked on a variety of applications
through my career starting out the video
compression that is that's a space where
you know energy efficiency is really
really critical right so you have video
compression on all of your phones and
they're hard coding it is very key and
it actually works out well because
there's you know some form of
standardization you still need a little
bit of flexibility for the encoder to
you know for companies to differentiate
between the products at the other
extreme
still have things like deep learning
which are continuing to evolve so
obviously a lot of flexibility there is
very key to be very critical if you want
to keep up with the new alguns the new
models and then there's someplace in
between where in terms of Robotics you
want it to be still efficient but you
want to be able to adapt to for example
different environments where you
navigate so you still have to have some
form of flexibility there so from my
view it really depends on what is the
application and where on that
flexibility efficiency curve you want to
be it makes good sense
for Andrew I'm gonna actually is this
okay I'm gonna go to the second question
which is when I was going to ask you is
about when do you think that that
quantum and I'm sorry I was gonna ask
Jerry little I was just like Alice and I
went wait a minute Jerry when do you
think quantum and AI are really going to
intersect specifically Alan and what
steps do you think those first ones
would be yeah no that's a really great
question I think that quantum computing
and how it intersects with machine
learning is a really really hot topic
right now there's a lot of research
going into how those threads mesh right
and the whole the whole concept though
behind it is really how can we use the
fact that quantum computing these qubits
give us access to this very very rich
and large state space of exploration how
do we use that to effectively look at
machine learning type problems where you
also might have a very rich and deep
feature space are there connections
there where we can in fact find the
classification planes using the quantum
space more efficiently than you would in
a particularly deep neural network so
there's a lot of thoughts about how you
would actually map problems with
classical data that you want to actually
classify onto these these these quantum
quantum computers but all I can say
right now is it's it's an active area of
interest there's very there's there's a
lot of research going into it and I
think that you know we're really excited
about it
Jerry I had a follow-up question if
that's all right please that's even
better so I'm curious about the energy
usage of quantum computing so it's clear
the computing can do
massive searches very quickly but my
guess is that the energy consumption is
pretty large and that it's larger now
than it would be had we done the same
computation on on silicon hardware
it's the crossover gonna happen so
you're right actually it's the energy
consumption is not very large
all right so even though we are using
these systems to cool down these
processors to very low temperatures
that's a fixed amount of of power
effectively you need to run a couple of
cryocoolers with which which take up
some energy but it's certainly not
nowhere near a HPC centers amount of
power and for that matter
currently we are we're starting to build
these systems to the point where the
number of qubits within them that state
space is starting to grow large enough
that you can simulate that on a
traditional computer any traditional
computer and so as we are getting
towards this realm of say 50 100 or more
qubits you're really pushing up against
that barrier of at least some aspect of
the system is beyond what you can
simulate with with any high-performance
computer Andrew let me ask you I just
kind of to go back to that system that I
was really taken by the conference the
point you made on power do you foresee a
day when we're actually you know getting
a POW I mean a like a carbon price tag
for our algorithms like that we would
choose how much hyper parameter stuff we
would do I mean cost is one thing right
we know how much it cost but do you
foresee a day where you know where we'll
actually know the the carbon footprint
of our calculations on our different
choices yeah I'm marking that that's the
way that researchers should be thinking
now and that they should be reporting
figures that would enable carbon to be
calculated as part of their current
other current papers and I think it
advances in hardware well I think
quantum computing is almost as just a
different animal and so incredibly
wonderful that not even did I I'm not
sure quite what to say about that but in
silicon computation I think that you
know advances in hardware design like TP
use and other and other similar things
are going to be helpful but in a way I
say with some guilt that the
she's learning community will just
consume hungrily whatever we're provided
with and I don't really think about it
as as a major solution what I what I
think about as an as a stronger solution
is I think things that actually relate
to what Joshua Tenenbaum was talking
about earlier learning that's more
human-like
learning that's done into in lifelong
fashion rather than training a model
from scratch for every new problem we'll
be able to build on a lot of training
that's already been done and to learn
some new related tasks just to a small
amount of training on top of that and
you know for all of the complaints that
I had about birch and how much carbon
it's using now that's already I think a
small example of a step in that
direction because Google released the
Train parameters for their Berk model
and there are many people who just
consumed those parameters and do a
little bit of training on top I'm
arguing that that should have a lot more
in the future so I guess that to take
that point and ask song and to go to the
slide oh you know when you think about
the trade-off between hardware and
software how much do you think hardware
can solve this problem versus software
algorithms how do we allocate our effort
you know I know we have to do both but
where do you see the biggest energy
savings being do you think there's a
magic bullet in hardware
or do you think it will be through
software and approach yeah that's a good
point I can start by giving an example
from a previous work on keep compression
from the algorithm side and efficient
difference and in the accelerator size
side for example for tip compression we
can make the model an order of magnitude
smaller right so that's roughly ten
times if you can think about it
and from the hardware side we can
squeeze everything from Tehran to Iran
so that's immediately from 240 Pico
joules per word to only like five people
tools pervert that's like two orders of
magnitude saving so that's just one
example the saving from software like
one order of magnitude from hardware to
others of magnitude however it's not
possible to have this D Ram drives as
RAM case without the model compression
if the model is so large you have to
access the RAM it's
even not possible to have those two
others of magnitude saving from from the
hopper side so the co.design is really
important it's good I live in one of the
things that I think about is is the
answer you know some of that is going to
come from the hardware innovation I mean
when I look think about edge I think
about there's the huge diversity and
standards and stuff I was an IOT guy and
I kind of wonder you know do you
envision large-scale deployments of edge
based IOT and what would drive the
unification of that so it was a single
addressable software environment or do
you think it's gonna always be it
depends I think it depends I think it's
a very big business question right I
think there's been many it's a very
fragmented space right now as I
understand it from the IOT space so how
to unify that and what is it that would
bring it together is certainly well what
can I push a little harder on that is do
you think that some great software
innovation of standardization would
drive the hardware people to to kind of
get in line you know and you know kind
of a combined cloud and edge kind of
thing that would be so compelling that
people would converge if people are
using it than the hardware people will
come and provide hardware for it but
it's kind of yeah taking it yeah be kind
of an interesting I I don't know what
the answer is you had a related question
yeah so do you think would you say that
on the whole putting computing at the
edge it reduces power consumption or
there are economies of scale of having
the computation happen mostly in a
central location and I know that for
individual systems that could go either
way but I just wondered as a broad trend
you could say it's certainly saves so
one of the most expensive parts of
computing the edge is communication hmm
right so it's just like moving data is
always expensive so moving data far away
even off the chip to the cloud is
expensive so I think you can factor that
in I think there's a lot of in addition
to the energy there's a lot of you know
benefits of doing in the edge like I was
talking about in terms of latency
privacy I think in the edge you
also have the benefit I guess some
diversity where you can really tailor it
towards your particular application
whereas in the cloud it tends to be more
general-purpose because you just serve
many clients right so that flexibility
versus efficiency trade-off you might
make a different decision if you're on
the edge in which case can be more
efficient yeah so I'd like to think
about these ecosystems and Gerry I'll go
to you and you know it's been very
interesting to see how you know quantum
you've been you've worked very hard
early on to build that ecosystem and to
try to train people and and the sort of
crowdsourcing of that ideas what kinds
of insights have you gotten from people
outside of your own development area
that have influenced the you know the
actual evolution of that yeah song I'll
ask you a similar question in hardware
to again I know that's a great question
especially with the with the queue
experience but the software stack that
we've defined it with in kiss kit it
allows to have a broad array of
end-users to contribute so we have those
that want to sit at the very top who
want to explore say new new applications
and algorithms and chemistry or machine
learning optimization you have those
that want to actually be in the middle I
want to actually study some of the
nitty-gritty details of what you would
call the the guts of the the software
stack so things like compilers coming up
with new compilers that allow you to
translate the end algorithms into a
smaller number of the underlying gates
we've seen people develop faster
compilers in fact and then we had in the
in in our lab as well as coming up with
ways of characterizing noise and
visualizing some of the end States you
see a lot of people looking into trying
to benchmark the quality of the
underlying processor because that itself
as these quantum processors grow and
become more and more difficult and of a
challenge to benchmark them properly and
you see a lot of people innovating and
thinking about ways to do that in a
somewhat related they give your doing
song you're doing Auto ml right and so
as we start to move towards automation
do you are you finding that the
algorithms are giving you insights that
you're a human designer now
designer for neural networks would never
have I mean coming up with something
that's non-intuitive yeah yeah that's a
good point
so you recently we are working on auto
ml techniques to automatically find a
new neural net architectures and also
hardware architectures and we did find
since there's a super large design space
human you really use those rule-based
heuristics like you should use three by
three small kernels bypass layers
inverted bottleneck those rule-based
heuristics those prints are those
primitives but opening up opening up the
largest designs to base and just give
the AI reward function tell him what is
good what is bad and you explore on
yourself what is a good architecture
that not only ran fast but also give
good accuracy and low energy and we find
some interesting phenomenons
for example on GPUs yeah we would prefer
a large kernel even like seven by seven
kernel with human designers has almost a
forgotten or ignored it since people
think three three by three kernels it
has 27 weights but one sandbox seven by
seven kernel having the same receptive
field they have 49 weights but people
neglected the fact that GPU has so large
parallelism is even not for you cannot
keep the gpo fully for a 44 it stays
hungry if you ran small kernels as a
result the agent is determined to use a
lots of large kernels or GPUs super
shadow quad shadow but large kernel well
for CPUs they prefer to use very deep
layers and small kernels and this is
just between CPU and GPU with CMOS
technology and even imagine in the
future when we have new technologies
different hardware maybe the algorithm
will be completely different and human
design it'll be we can do heretics but
it'll be even better if we can have
those new heuristic from AI just to ask
kind of a follow-on question adapting
from one of the slider questions is that
do you imagine that in an age where most
do it first of all do you imagine that
there will be a time when most models
are developed using auto ml if what
other models can develop can be
developed using ultra
there's some challenges for example the
search cost is very high we are treating
GPU hours for human hours right
for example we mentioned the co2
emission we calculated the initial
neural architecture search from Google
it takes 11,000 tons of co2 and how much
is that that's like five trips from four
light trips one person from New York to
San Francisco you'll fly five times one
person that causes 11,000 pounds I mean
about student dinners that's a hundred K
dollars like a PhD year but however we
did see some opportunity like my
students the developers matter algorithm
by making latency differentiable so you
can directly do back propagation and
search those architectural parameters
learning not only the weights but also
the architecture so we cut the search
cost to only about fifty pounds fifty
pounds of co2 emissions that's the part
of the why human breath for two days
does the amount of co2 emission so we
still see some promising directions you
start on out design the model it's good
Vivian there was a question up there
that scrolled off but it you know it in
terms of the the dance between memory
and logic what do you see the the
migration of sort of memory centric
computing we were talking about it
earlier on how do you see that playing
out here yeah I mean I think they
there's certainly been a lot of
interesting research in the space of
process processing near processing in
memory since data movements very
expensive the idea there is that if I
can bring the compute to where the
weights are at then I really
significantly reduce the amount of power
that I can I need to consume there I'm
actually we had our project sponsored by
IBM on this topic as well and think this
actually echoes a lot of stuff that song
was mentioning to which is that
basically one of the challenges there if
you're moving all the processing into
memories also you might need to think of
how to design your algorithms that are
more tailored towards this type of
processing architecture so one of the
big benefits and also big challenges of
these processing memories that you
build these very large arrays of weights
to store your data itself and to amort
and that's useful for density reasons
and also to amortize the cost of moving
the activations or the inputs and in it
out of the weight array itself but the
existing networks that people have been
using they've been trying to make it
smaller and more narrow and so as a
result you can't really fully utilize
the full array in processing memory so
the question is how can you redesign
some algorithms that map better to this
particular hardware and just really a
once again bringing the hardware into
the loop when you're optimizing the
algorithms for these even more exciting
or future looking platforms so I think
it's very promising but it's important
to kind of look at it holistically not
just as a piece of hardware but you know
so oh yeah I was gonna ask you anything
go ahead oh well actually I was gonna
ask you a separate question please do it
that's why based on the third question
that I see and yes please oh so I
understand that in the past IBM or maybe
hopefully still it was working on analog
computing which I think it could be a
great efficiency let's talk let's ask
just across the panel so I'm an analog
person we all are actually keep that in
mind
and you know there's a lot of promising
technology tomorrow there's gonna be a
session I think the third the third
section tomorrow I think
is it number three session three and
where they're actually going to be
talking about that but you know logic
has its you know has had a long run
do you anticipate do any of the
panelists anticipate that these kind of
new analog like analog neural nets or
any of those kind of technologies will
have a major impact on on AI before we
move to quantum or yes the process okay
good got you down what do you think
is actually doing analog you're using AI
to optimize analog circuits what do you
think the promise of non digital
circuits for AI I mean we're using 20
watts here and you know megawatts there
so is there some so basically deep
learning is using multiplication and add
as a basic operation so the way to
minimize the
hower is minimizing the number of
switches from digital so if analog
devices we can have reduce the amount of
switches and I also have the scale that
digital circuits can provide I think we
can do some useful useful stuff provide
both high precision reasonable amount of
precision and reasonable reasonable
amount of parallelism as long as we can
do them physically yeah you do you see
that yeah so I think like it aligns with
basically well so I want to be analog
computers posted I'm not exactly sure
what analog neural nets are but analog
compute inter in the context of like
processing and memory is certainly in a
space that a lot of people are pushing
through and it offers a lot of processes
a lot of challenges to in terms of the
fabrication and the scaling up of the
design and as we mentioned like the
mapping of the algorithm onto that
platform but certainly it in terms of
density and the opportunity minimize
data movement it has promise and there's
a lot of new devices so with that I
think if I understand what this thing is
telling me this analog it's a digital
analog readout here is I believe that
we've gotten to the the end of our time
can I ask everybody just to have a you
know what do you think the biggest
impact in in AI technology is going to
be as we progress just a three word
sentence is that too hard okay everybody
think for 30 seconds what would I say
anyone want to offer this is the the
graduate moment where somebody says in
class yes yeah I would reiterate
lifelong learning without training
systems from scratch having strong
priors yeah we go several us so I say
it's the first letter of my first name
but I also stand for small models for
inference small write efficient scalable
system for trinium right go large for
training and specialized the silicon
space ionised specialize the city key to
making efficient for us got three these
were what I would add is that I mean
we've we talked a little bit today about
how quantum computing could make a
difference for machine learning
the flipside is actually true there's a
lot of effort in fact with the MIT aai
collaboration right now looking MIT an
IBM collaboration again how machine
learning methods can help us understand
and characterize the underlying quantum
systems better and so from that actually
develop understand annoys and build
better systems for the future all right
so I'll I'll fit into a v1v so vertical
integration so looking across the entire
stack I think it's really important to
look at all the different layers and how
they interact and really think about the
application challenges that we're having
and try and optimize across everything
degree I think you all rose to that
challenge very well so thank you all
very much I think that is is that the
end of our the program for today I think
so just my talk ok I'm off
[Applause]